[Music]
one of the most interesting articles
I've come across in the last couple of
years is Alain de Botton z-- article on
the fact that museums need to do a
better job at creating spaces that
trigger encounters with the sacred in
other words he thinks that we need
better secular institutions in which to
experience the transcendent
human beings longed for these encounters
with the epic to rub up against the
numinous we wake up and we want our life
to have meaning go to church on Sunday
we look at beautiful cathedrals and
experience some kind of awe whether or
not we are believers the spaces
themselves seem to induce it and
religions understand this well but do
secular institutions I mean aside from
the movie theater aside from the IMAX
screen occasionally playing a film like
Inception and conjuring up the cosmic
are that only brilliant sci-fi I can
conjure we don't have that many spaces
for this kind of stuff you know there
was an article called Goldeneye written
by Ross Anderson that spoke of the
Hubble Space Telescope and how it was an
instrument of man was the eye of man an
exoskeleton of man's optic nerve
literally allowing us to mainline the
whole of time through the optic nerve
and it does allow us to do that the
Hubble instruments of science that
expand what we can see they do expand
our minds they do help us rub up against
the numinous the intricate order the
pattern that connects this is the thing
that these things do but only under
certain compressed modes of
presentations if it wasn't for Ross
Anderson's overly articulate and poetic
distillation of what the Hubble does I
might not have thought of it that way if
I didn't have the context in which to
understand the role of the Hubble and
expanding human consciousness I might
not have been able to
appreciated fully and so again going
back to the Alain de Botton idea how can
we create more spaces more institutions
more interfaces that mediate our
encounters with the epic our encounters
with the sacred because we need that
[Music]